[Music]
hi it's Michele from lab muffin beauty
science here chemistry PhD and beauty
science nerd today we're going to be
talking about skincare myths if you
follow me on instagram at lab moth and
beauty science you'll know that I
regularly post about myths about beauty
and a lot of the time these are skincare
myths today I'm going to be talking
about some of these and what you should
do instead if you like beauty
myth-busting then you might want to
follow me on Instagram I bust myths
about every second day also you can also
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
check out my blog on Facebook myths
number one pulls open when you put warm
water on your face and clothes when you
put cold water on your face this myth
has been around forever and it refuses
to die you'll see lots of advice telling
you to use a warm cloth on your face
before cleansing to open up your pores
so that you can get inside them and
clean them out and then afterwards
you're meant to splash cold water on
your face or even rub ice over your face
to close all your pores up again
I think this myth comes from the fact
that muscles do work this way warm
temperatures relax muscles and cold
temperatures tensed your muscles up this
is why the hairs on your skin stand up
when it's cold and relaxed back down
when it's warm the problem here is that
the muscles that pull your hair up and
down director of pili muscles these
costs goosebumps but they don't control
whether your pore opens or closes the
opening will move back and forth but it
doesn't actually open and close in fact
there aren't any muscles that control
the pore opening it's just a hole in
your skin the problem from switching
between hot and cold is that these
extreme temperatures will irritate your
skin and irritation is linked to a lot
of bad things in your skin like pimples
so don't put your skin through their
sort of treatment a little bit of warmth
can help oils become runya so that they
come out of your pores more easily and a
little bit of cold can be good for
calming down inflammation but if you try
to push between really really hot and
really cold temperatures this will just
irritate your
for no good reason myth number two if
you clean your skin more thoroughly
it'll help you with your acne pimples
make your skin look uneven and having
Josh on your skin can cause acne so it's
pretty obvious that if you clean your
skin more they'll stop acne from forming
right well no cleaning more usually
doesn't fix your acne there are four
main factors that will contribute your
acne these are excess oil production
inflammation overgrowth of specific
bacteria and clogged pores cleansing can
help with oil production and overgrowth
of bacteria and clogged pores if you're
using a product that is about to clog
your pores but if you cleanse
incorrectly such as if you use cleansers
that are too harsh or if you overdo your
cleansing this can actually make those
four factors worse for example if you
use a high pH cleanser this can lead to
inflammation and overgrowth of acne
bacteria if you use a harsh and
irritating cleanser this can lead to
inflammation and it can increase your
oil production
you only need to cleanse once or twice a
day with a gentle cleanser that's the
right pH and contains gentle surfactants
I've put a few examples of gentle
cleansers in the comments myth number
three natural skincare is better for
sensitive skin a lot of natural beauty
brands push the idea that natural beauty
products are gentler and more benign on
your skin so they're going to be great
for sensitive skin I touched on this
myth before in my video on natural and
chemical beauty products the first thing
we need to clear up is that everything
is a chemical
[Music]
one of the big misconceptions about
nature is that nature isn't quite as
nice and idyllic
as they usually make it out to be so for
example if you have hay fever like me
you know that nature is evil and makes
you sneezy if you've been stung by a bee
or if you've touched poison ivy or
stinging nettles then you'll have been
on the receiving end of some of nature's
wrath
if you think of the things that people
tend to be deathly allergic to like bee
stings peanuts wheat fish and milk these
tend to be natural things in nature have
evolved to defend themselves and at the
same time we've become more allergic to
more things cells actually synthetic
products that tend to be better for
sensitive skin natural extracts also
tend to be mixtures of complex chemicals
and there's a lot more variation in them
as well for example an apple extract
from a ripe Apple is going to have
different chemicals in it than an Apple
extract from an unripe Apple and this
will be different from an extract from
an apple that's been left to rot in a
warehouse natural ingredients also often
contain hidden fragrances which can be
pretty allergenic synthetic products on
the other hand are usually simpler and
they have ingredients that are actually
just a single chemical they're also less
affected by things like the season and
where that extra comes from this means
that it's going to be a lot easier to
predict how your skin will react to a
synthetic product and that's why Jo
mythologies tend to recommend synthetic
products for people with sensitive skin
myth number four chemical sunscreens
need to absorb and activate before they
start to work and protect your skin from
the Sun there's a widespread myth that
chemical organic sunscreen ingredients
need to absorb and bind your skin and
then they need to activate before they
start working and absorbing UV but
physical or inorganic sunscreens that
contains zinc oxide or titanium dioxide
don't need this waiting time so this
means you see a lot of advice saying
that you need to put on chemical
sunscreens earlier and wait for 20
minutes before going out into the Sun
whereas you can put on a physical
sunscreen and they'll start working
immediately this myth also means that
you'll see advice telling you that you
need to apply chemical sunscreens on
bare skin
otherwise they won't work but physical
sunscreens don't need bare skin and you
should put them on top of your makeup
this myth probably partly comes from the
fact that instructions on sunscreen
packaging often tell you to apply 20
minutes before going into the Sun but
the reason for this isn't because the
sunscreen needs to activate sunscreen
ingredients both chemical and physical
are active and capable of absorbing UV
even before they leave the bottle here I
smeared
screen onto white paper and they're
absorbing UV from the backlight
immediately after I've applied it the
reason for this 20-minute wait time is
that the sunscreen needs to spread and
form a film so it doesn't get rubbed off
sunscreens are emulsions that contain
droplets of water in oil so until the
sunscreen comes together to form an even
film it can give spotty protection if it
hasn't formed a film and you move around
too much it can rub off and again you
end up with incomplete protection this
way time for the film to form is the
same for both chemical and physical
sunscreens and after this film forms
both chemical and physical sunscreens
are mostly sitting on top of the skin in
a uniform layer hopefully so that it
protects the skin underneath so this
means that you can treat chemical and
physical sunscreens the same way you
don't need to apply chemical sunscreen
as the first layer and physical
sunscreen as the last layer and you
don't need to wait for one type and not
the other if you want to learn more
about sunscreen I go into tons more
detail about how to apply sunscreen in
my sunscreen and makeup video and more
about sunscreen in general in the lab
Morphin guide to basic skin care myth
number 5 people with good skin have good
skin care routines it's really tempting
to see someone with good skin and ask
them for their routine so you can copy
it or follow all their tips so that you
can get skin like this but unfortunately
good skin doesn't necessarily mean that
someone's got good skincare habits one
of the biggest reasons that people have
healthy skin or healthy bodies in
general is genetics because good skin is
based on genetics it's a little bit like
asking someone who's tall how to get
taller following their routine probably
isn't going to make you any taller some
people can throw anything at their skin
and I'll still be smooth and clear
that's why really bad ideas like
toothpaste to clear up spots still get
rave reviews pimples will clear up on
their own in a few days if your skin is
good and if you only have one pimple and
you put toothpaste on it then you don't
know how long it would have taken for it
to heal with or without the toothpaste
and so it look like putting toothpaste
on it
at Hill there's a popular saying in
science which is that correlation is not
causation this means that if you do
something and something else happens
afterwards it doesn't mean that the
first thing caused the second thing for
example if my alarm goes off in the
morning and then I miss my train that
doesn't mean that my alarm calls me to
miss my train
but it's really tempting to see things
as related because humans like things to
make sense this is one of the big issues
with anecdotal evidence which is when
people give testimonials saying that
something worked for them a lot of the
time things aren't related and a lot of
conditions get better on their own
without interference so this goes for
skin care as well as other areas of
health like waiting for a cold to get
better so coal remedies a lot of the
time they are just old wives tales
did you believe any other myths leave me
a comment below and tell me the myths
you were most surprised to find out what
actually myths make sure you subscribe
and hit the notification button see you
next time for more beauty science
you